well it was very very exciting just to
talk to lynn about the vaccine that
she's just taken
she's 81 and really very moving to hear
her say that she's doing it
for britain and and that's exactly right
because she's protecting herself but
she's also helping
to protect the entire country and across
the the whole of the uk
uh this morning that is happening in all
in scotland northern ireland and wales
in england people are having the vaccine
for the first time
and it will gradually make a huge huge
difference
but i stress gradually because you know
we're not
there yet we haven't defeated this virus
yet and it's
very important for people to understand
so it's quite hard to speak through this
but
it's important people to understand that
the virus
is alas still rising in in some parts of
the
of the country it's it's rising for
instance in
london we've got it down hugely as a
result of the measures we took
in uh in november
which have just come off people made a
huge huge effort
we can't afford to relax now and so my
message would be
it's amazing to see the vaccine coming
out it's amazing to see this tremendous
shot in the arm for the entire nation
but we can't afford to relax now
what would you say to those people that
are scared about getting in the vaccine
well i would just say to all those who
are
who are scared um don't be and you
you've seen
uh lynn take it you've seen paul you've
seen people take the vaccine this
morning
in large numbers people are going to be
taking in the next few days and
and weeks and there's nothing to be uh
nervous about
and what i would say excuse me uh sorry
you get this thing
probably what i would say is that um
there are those obviously who feel that
a
a vaccine is something they object to uh
politically or for ideological reasons
uh or for medical reasons i i think
they're totally wrong
i know that there are loads of people
who who count themselves anti-vaxxers
and that's totally the wrong approach
it's safe
it's the right thing to do it's good for
you and it's good for the whole of the
country
are you confident that the system can
cope with this roll out
well it's going to take a while i want
to stress that it will take you know
weeks and months rather than just days
to get all this done
obviously the nhs is going to work as
fast as it as it possibly can
and i'm extremely proud and impressed
with uh
with what the nhs is doing this morning
but
you know it will it will be it will be a
right the way through for the next few
months so i just urge people to contain
their
impatience uh it's a very very exciting
moment but there's still
a lot of work to be done and a lot of
discipline to be maintained
on brexit unsurprisingly are you hopeful
that you are going to get a deal
i'm always hopeful yeah so i'm very
hopeful um but i've got to be honest
with you i think the situation at the
moment
is is very tricky i think that um
our our friends have just got to
understand that
uh the uk has left the european union in
order
uh to be able to exercise democratic
control over
over the way we do things and then
there's also the issue of
fisheries where we're a long way apart
still but you know
hope springs eternal and um i i'll
i'll i'll do my best to sort it out if
we can
but i want to stress one thing this is
very very important i think people need
to
need to realize that whatever happens
it's
it's going to be a different on january
the 1st you know whatever kind of deal
we get whether it's going to be
like australia or like canada there's
going to be
change and businesses and people need to
get ready for that change i hope
everybody
everybody understands that will you keep
trying for a deal right up until the
wire
of course we're always hopeful but
you know there may come a moment when we
have to acknowledge that it's time to
to draw stumps and and that's that's
just the way it is but
you know we will prosper mightily as
i've always said under any
uh under any version and uh if we have
to go for an australian solution
then that's fine too uh i just want to
say
you know one thing about uh um
the the current situation i i didn't
mention one thing about the
the the state of the pandemic and i made
i made a point about how it's
the diseases is rising in in some parts
between falling massively it's one
crucial point that i want to get over to
people
we're finding that people don't realize
quite how easy it is
to transmit this disease
asymptomatically
without symptoms and one in three people
is passing it on without even having any
symptoms
at all yourself do you see what i mean
so you can be a secret spreader
of the disease i don't think people have
have grasped that and
it's very very important in the weeks
ahead that everybody
understands that we didn't realize at
the beginning quite how easily
the disease can be spread without
symptoms it's very very important people
think about that think that they could
be
you and i we could be i mean
transmitting it without
actually having the symptoms just to
drive you back to brexit how confident
are you that meeting face-to-face is
going to make any difference at all
well i've you've got to be you've got to
be optimistic you've got to believe that
there's the the power of sweet reason uh
to to get this thing over the line but
i've got to tell you
it's looking very very difficult at the
moment and you know
we'll do we'll do our level best but i
would just say to everybody
uh be a good cheer it will be you know
those that there are there are great
options ahead for our country
on any view but the key thing is uh on
january the 1st
whatever happens there's going to be
change and people need to get ready for
that change
do you think that going to brussels is
that really just you trying to show that
you have tried everything is that the
main reason that you're going
i i think the the we'll see where we get
to in the course of the next
few days um but i think the uk
government's position is that
we're willing to engage at any level
political
or otherwise willing to to try anything
dearly of course we are
but there are just there are just limits
beyond which
obviously uh no sensible independent
government to all country could could go
and and people have got to understand
last question before i get whacked
and what would you say to people that
work in business who are terrified that
you're not going to get a deal
well i think that everybody needs to
understand that
on any view there's going to be change
on january the 1st
and if we have to come out on australian
terms as they're called
then we'll make sure that we look after
everybody in this country of course
but also i think people need to need to
recognize that
this is a big big opportunity for this
country on any view
and uh yes we'll be able to do things
differently but we'll be able to do
many things better as well and there are
big big opportunities for the uk whether
it's canada
or australia i'm very confident either